Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute eine weitere sehr, sehr leckere Erdbeertorte.
Wenn ihr mich kennt, wisst ihr: Die Erdbeersaison muss komplett ausgenutzt werden!
Und daher freue ich mich riesig, dass ich euch so leckere Rezepte zeigen kann.
Heute gibt's eine leckere, erfrischende Torte, die auch optisch richtig was hermacht.
Und das Ganze geht sehr, sehr einfach. Haltet euch einfach Schritt für Schritt an die Anleitung,
dann klappt das auch, egal, ob ihr jetzt Anfänger seid oder schon geübte Bäckerinnen und Bäcker.
Ich werde euch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben wie immer hier unten in der Videobeschreibung aufschreiben,
dann könnt ihr's einfach screenshotten und einkaufen gehen.
Ich fange direkt an mit meinem Teig.
Das wird ein locker-luftiger Teig ohne Eiertrennen, also super unkompliziert.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt die Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt aber auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden, dann braucht ihr nur so 2-3min länger.
Und da gebe ich jetzt Eier, gleich noch eine Prise Salz,
Zucker und Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Und der Trick dabei ist, dass ihr später noch warmes Wasser hinzufügt
und dann richtig schön schlagen, ungefähr 5-6min lang.
Die Masse ist jetzt richtig schön dick-cremig geworden.
Genauso brauchen wir sie auch und als nächstes kommen die trockenen Zutaten dazu.
Da habe ich Mehl, Speisestärke und Backpulver.
Und jetzt ist es ganz wichtig, dass wir das Ganze vorher noch einmal durchsieben
und dann mit einem Teigschaber richtig schön mit ganz viel Liebe unterheben.
Sobald sich die Mehlnester dann vollständig aufgelöst haben, ist der Teig fertig,
das dauert also wirklich nicht lange.
Und ich mache jetzt mit meinem Tortenring weiter, ich hab den hier auf 24cm Durchmesser eingestellt.
Falls ihr euch fragt: "Kann ich auch eine Springform verwenden?"
Selbstverständlich, das ist gar kein Problem.
Ich benutze z.B. auch sehr gerne Springformen.
Ich mache das immer je nach Gefühl, nach Rezept,
je nachdem, ob ich den Tortenring später noch weiterhin verwende - das mache ich nämlich in diesem Rezept.
Und daher wird's heute der Tortenring.
Ich schlage den aber noch ein, weil der keinen Boden hat.
Dafür einfach ein Backpapier unten drunter legen und das zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal.
Und dann immer schön am Rand entlang gehen
und dann klemmt sich das quasi automatisch ein.
Der Teig kommt jetzt in den vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze für 24min.
Anschließend einmal rausholen, zugedeckt abkühlen lassen und wir machen jetzt weiter mit der Creme.
Ich hab dafür jetzt einmal Schlagsahne - die ist ganz kalt und frisch aus dem Kühlschrank -
hab ich schonmal in meine Schüssel gegeben und werd die jetzt mit dem Handrührgerät einmal aufschlagen,
da gebe ich jetzt auch kein Sahnefest dazu. Und danach gehen wir rüber zum Herd.
So am Herd werde ich jetzt mit Agar Agar arbeiten, das ist pflanzliches Geliermittel,
besteht aus Algen und ist 'ne gute Alternative zur Gelatine falls ihr die nicht verwenden möchtet.
Und dafür gebe ich einfach Wasser und Agar Agar jetzt in meine Pfanne,
- Das ist eine Hochrandpfanne. Nicht wundern, die ist ein bisschen höher -
und werde das jetzt 2min lang sprudelnd kochen lassen.
Und dann entfalten sich die Geliereigenschaften, diese 2min sind deshalb wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig.
Nach den 2min dann einmal den Topf vom Herd ziehen
und die Mascarpone einrühren sodass sie klümpchenfrei ist.
Es ist ganz normal, dass sie dann etwas weicher wird, gleich wird alles noch richtig schön fest.
Ich gebe jetzt noch Magerquark und Zucker mit dazu.
Ich finde, dass einfach die Kombination aus Magerquark, Mascarpone und Sahne ohnehin schon super lecker ist.
Aber wir haben ja heute noch so 'nen kleine Star Gast - so, Zucker noch mit rein -
und zwar nehme ich die Konfitüre von d'arbo.
Da hat mich ehrlicherweise meine Mama ein bisschen angefixt, die kauft schon seit Jahren die d'arbo Konfitüre.
Hier in der Sorte Gartenerdbeeren und wenn ihr das Glas einmal öffnet..
einmal dran riechen, das riecht so gut!
Und da gebe ich jetzt noch 2 richtig pralle Esslöffel von mit hier rein
und das macht auch am Ende nochmal den ganzen Geschmack aus.
So, wir können jetzt auch direkt die aufgeschlagene Sahne unterheben.
Ich nehme jetzt dafür aber keine Schneebesen mehr, sondern meine...?
[Hamza] Teigschaber!
[Kiki] Meinen Teigschaber!
Ich hatte grad 'nen kurzen Aussetzer!
So, und da gebe ich jetzt einfach die komplette Sahne mit rein und hebe sie unter
und dann ist die Creme auch schon fertig.
Ich hab jetzt noch die frischen Erdbeeren vorbereitet
und meinen Boden aus der Form befreit und halbiert.
Jetzt habe ich mir eine weiße Tortenplatte genommen und schonmal den ersten Boden darübergelegt.
Ich mach's so, dass ich den Deckel nehme damit ich den eigentlichen Boden als Deckel nehmen kann
damit's 'nen geraden Abschluss hat aber das könnt ihr auch machen, wie ihr möchtet.
Ich werde jetzt nochmal von der d'arbo Konfitüre einmal in die Mitte geben.
Übrigens: Das ist die naturreine Sorte, d'arbo hat verschiedene Sorten.
Probiert euch gerne mal durch.
Ich werde davon jetzt auch wieder 2 Esslöffel in die Mitte geben
und schön verstreichen, das gibt nochmal so 'nen schönen, fruchtigen Kick.
Die langen Erdbeerstücke jetzt ganz einfach an den Rand des Tortenrings geben
und macht euch keine Sorgen, das hält wie von alleine.
Und anschließend den Rest nochmal ein bisschen feiner schneiden.
Die Erdbeeren gebe ich jetzt in die Mitte, verteile dann die Creme oben drüber
und dann kommt auch schon der Deckel darauf.
So, und jetzt das Ganze einmal schön ordentlich durchkühlen.
Ihr habt ja gerade gesehen: Die Creme ist schon sehr, sehr flüssig noch,
also es muss schon richtig schön schnittfest werden.
Dafür braucht es 4h Kühlzeit, super gerne auch über Nacht.
Also könnt ihr das Ganze praktisch am Vortag vorbereiten
und dann fehlt eigentlich nur noch die Dekoration.
Und nach der Kühlzeit könnt ihr dann einfach nach Herzenslust dekorieren.
Ich z.B. mag's mit Puderzucker, natürlich immer frischen Erdbeeren on top,
frische Minze passt immer sehr gut, aber auch z.B. Baiser, Schleierkraut..
Ach, macht da drauf, soviel ihr möchtet. Hauptsache es gefällt euch!
Ich finde grundsätzlich die Torte wunderschön wegen dem äußeren Erdbeerrand
und geschmacklich einfach top!
Ich wünsche euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen, freue mich über eure Fotos auf Instagram
und wünsche euch ansonsten noch einen wunderwunderschönen Tag.
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss, eure Kiki!